our heart pumps blood in our body and  that helps all the organs function we  have various organs for performing  different functions in the body what are  these organs made up of they are made up  of tissues  tissues are groups of cells that have a  similar structure and act together to  perform a specific function the word  tissue comes from a form of an old  french verb meaning to weave  there are four different types of  tissues in animals connective muscle  nervous and epithelial in plants tissues  are divided into three types  vascular ground and epidermal  groups of tissues make up organs in the  body  now do you know the largest organ in the  human body please share your answers in  the comments section  [Music]